eine Windrad Baustelle mitten im
Schwarzwald am Steuer dieses superkrans
Sascha braun was kann das schief gehen
dass der Kran dann in der Überlast
bekommen oder so dass das anfängt zu
schaukeln dass Finger dazwischen sind
wir dürfen Kranfahrer Sascha und seine
Kollegen bei der Arbeit begleiten zeigen
wie Sie dieses neue Windrad des Typs
v126 aufbauen bis zur Narbe ist es 149 m
hoch hat einen Rotor Durchmesser von 126
Metern und eine Leistung von 3,45
Megawatt zwei dieser Anlagen sollen hier
zukünftig den jährlichen Strombedarf von
3600 Haushalten produzieren doch auf
dieser Baustelle läuft nicht alles nach
Plan
noch lagern die Rotorblätter 11 km
entfernt auf diesem Parkplatz
in unserem Zeitplan heute ein bisschen
Manuel destler und sein Kollege sind für
den Transport zuständig und wahre Profis
schon mehr als 600 Rotorblätter haben
Sie mit dieser Spezialmaschine
transportiert gesteuert wird sie per
Fernbedienung
diese Maschine kann viel es ist wie Lego
es ist ein selbstfahrender
propell-modul driver sbnt der Name und
jetzt mit einem Blade Lüfter Tool
aufgebaut also man kann diese mit dieser
Maschine alles machen mindestens ein
Rotorblatt soll heute noch vom Tal auf
die Anhöhe gebracht werden damit das
klappt müssen Sie sich beeilen wenn der
Feierabendverkehr losgeht dürfen sie die
Bundesstraße nicht mehr blockieren
man muss immer bei klaren Gedanken sein
also man darf nie die Routine aufkommen
lassen bei jedem Transport muss man neu
behandeln weil wenn man eine Routine auf
kommt dann ist es ganz schlecht
die Monteure des turbinenherstellers
befestigen das Blatt mit 120 Bolzen denn
es ist 62 m lang und wiegt 14,8 Tonnen
weil wir haben hier ca 200 m²
Angriffsfläche und es kann natürlich
dann schon sehr heikel werden
vor ihnen liegen jetzt gleich drei
Stunden Fahrt so lange werden sie für
die 11,7 km zur Baustelle brauchen wir
haben eine Spitze Geschwindigkeit
zwischen 5 und 10 km/h in diesem Bereich
bewegen wir uns und wir können das Blatt
bis zu 60 Grad aufstellen 360° drehen
und je nachdem wie wir halt aufgestellt
haben und die Drücke passen dann so
haben wir die Fahrgeschwindigkeit also
es ist keine Rennmaschine
Manuel lenkt den Schwertransporter sein
Kollege Ralf steuert das Rotorblatt kann
es drehen und neigen das wird später
wenn es in den Wald geht noch wichtig
[Musik]
Bundesstraße haben hinter uns und jetzt
könnten wir uns durch den Wald nach oben
zur Anlage also das
heikle-stück weil da haben wir einige
baumpassagen und da muss man schauen
so gut wie möglich durchbringen wird
dieser schwierige Teil gelingen
und das Blatt pünktlich ankommen
zwei Tage vorher
hoch das will immer drüber sind und dann
zieht weiter hoch und fahre dann
entgegen okay
das Team rund um Kranfahrer Sascha setzt
die turmelemente aufeinander dabei ist
volle Konzentration gefragt aus der
Waagerechten stellen Sie das nächste
Element auf drei Monteure werden es
gleich annehmen exakt positionieren und
befestigen dabei kommt es auf jeden
Millimeter an
[Musik]
aber trotzdem braucht man da schon ein
bisschen Feingefühl ein bisschen
Erfahrung
hat er jahrelang vor Sascha Autokräne
jetzt lenkt der Kölner einen 1000 Tonnen
schweren Kran ist dafür sechs Tage die
Woche in ganz Deutschland unterwegs dann
hat man halt den Sonntag in der Regel
fahren wir dann auch wieder sonntags los
abends oder so dass man dann
am Abend wieder am Einsatzort ist quasi
da hat man halt einen Tag ein bisschen
für die Familie Freunde etc warum machst
du das
jeden Tag ist eine neue Herausforderung
man sieht ja hier im Schwarzwald das ist
ja ziemlich bergig also
es wird nie langweilig in dem Job also
mir jetzt mir gefällt das komplett die
Technik die ingenieurkskunst alles
der Spezialkran ist mehr als 150 Meter
hoch ihn aufzubauen dauert 30 Stunden
ist es zu windig oder gewittert müssen
die Arbeiten unterbrochen werden dann
geht Sicherheit vor
gerade kam bis zu 12 Meter Wind dann ja
ohne Probleme Arbeiten es wird ja immer
leichter nach oben also der Turm den wir
jetzt gesetzt haben hat 60 Stunden und
dann ging das schon
Regierung hat ein ambitioniertes Ziel
zwei Prozent der Fläche Deutschland
sollen bis 2032 für die Windenergie
ausgewiesen sein doch der Ausbau geht
nur schleppend voran Gründe dafür sind
neben strengen Auflagen und aufwendiger
Gutachten Fehlen des Personal
Lieferengpässe oder Proteste der
Bevölkerung gar Gerichtsverfahren
zwischen Idee und Bau eines Windrads wie
diesem können zwischen 6 und 10 Jahren
liegen
zurück zum rotorblatttransport vorbei an
35 Meter hohen Bäumen entlang scharfer
Kurven ganz behutsam lenken Manuel und
Ralf das 62 m lange Blatt den Hügel
hinauf
damit der Schwertransport hier überhaupt
fahren kann wurde der Waldweg extra
geteert
[Musik]
und wie liefs super für uns von
transportverlauf war es eigentlich wie
wir es uns gewünscht haben das
Rotorblatt ist unbeschadet und pünktlich
angekommen als wir ein paar Tage später
wieder vorbeischauen steht der ganze
Turm
was fehlt ist dieses letzte Rotorblatt
dafür ist Sascha wieder im engen Kontakt
mit seinen Kollegen unten am Boden und
oben auf der Gondel
sie hoffen dass es windstill bleibt denn
Windböen können das Blatt leicht zum
Schaukeln bringen
deswegen muss man auch hohe
Konzentration da oben mit allen
Gewerkschaften ob das Optimist ob es das
ground Team ist die alte Seile halten
dass das komplett gut abgesprochen ist
müssen vor allem verhindern dass das
Blatt gegen den Turm knallt jeder
einzelne hatten vom Gerät und darüber
kriegt jeder mit was gesprochen wird
müssen alle bei der Sache sein und
während des Liftes müssen alle
konzentriert sein
es hat alles gut geklappt das Windrad
steht nach einer Woche auf dieser
Baustelle hat Sascha jetzt Feierabend
also froh dass jetzt fertig ist
das nächste losgehen gleich gegenüber
werden sie ein zweites Windrad
aufstellen sobald beide angeschlossen
sind werden sie bei optimalen
Bedingungen pro Jahr 18.000
Megawattstunden Strom produzieren